hey youtubers it's Charlie this is gonna
be my Gotham finale video generally it
did live up to a little bit of the hype
they teased some really big things for
the second half of the season so I'm
gonna also talk about my just general
thoughts on the season in addition to
just this episode since we're heading
into the winter break leave all your
requests for bonus videos in the
comments below looking forward to doing
a lot of Batman videos careful for
spoilers from the episode if you're not
cut up but starting with top five
moments number five Falcone vs the mob
they kind of buried the lead in the last
episode when they blew his money up for
the most part it was meant to be like
that Joker scene from Dark Knight where
he just burns all the mobs money that's
not what they did I mean they blew up
part of it but the other half was
probably cease by the police it was just
intended to be like a crazy amount of
money which is why I'm surprised they
waited till this episode to show
Falcone's reaction it's pretty clear
that lies is the one that informed on
the location of the money lyza probably
not gonna live to see season two I am a
little frustrated with how easy it seems
for them to pull a fast one on Falcone
like you don't rise to the rank of mob
boss of his level without being really
smart Batman and Gotham are detective
shows so I'm expecting a little bit more
detective work from some of the
characters number four penguin versus
fish Mooney the biggest question is is
why is he biding his time why not just
take her out now he could be trying to
do the same thing to fish Mooney that
fish Mooney is trying to do to Falcone
like as fish slowly gets more powerful
penguin slowly weasels his way in so
we'll have a bigger pipe to steal when
it comes time to take over her
organization or take her power in some
way penguins family the cobblepot's are
historically wealthy people but I don't
think he's focused so much on the money
aspect as much as the power we really
started out with Falcone and a couple
mob players now we're starting to see
people from the Wayne foundation or from
the Wayne board of directors that's one
of the biggest criticisms of the show is
that they're introducing too many
villains too many big characters we'll
see how that goes I mean I'll give him
the benefit of the doubt right now but
most of my attention is on penguin and
his small circle that includes fish
Mooney Falcone and Maroni who we did not
see in this episode of all the character
arcs this season I feel like they've
serviced the Penguins the most I mean
they really put him forward as one of
the big protagonist of the series
even if he
kind of like an antihero technically
he's a villain but he's also kind of not
a villain in the way they're presenting
him just because there are people that
are so much worse than he is number
three Batman and Catwoman I really let
their scenes together I mean they're
really playful and it adds it's really
fun dimension to the show that's
supposed to be super dark generally I
tried to ignore like all the stunt work
it felt a little formulaic like it was
something out of like a full house
episode like them jumping around the
rooftops and having fun like them
devising a way to get rid of Copperhead
and the people tailing them there been a
lot of other comic book shows that have
taken that gritty handheld approach and
it just kind of spoils you in terms of
action really we need to blame arrow for
doing action so well they set the bar so
high that now anytime something is set
up and isn't done handheld it seems kind
of lame I know I made the comment
earlier that Gotham's stunt work just
isn't quite as good as arrow I feel like
they'll get there eventually I mean
they're still in the first season arrow
has gotten a lot better over time that's
what I'm expecting from Gotham - but I
would like to see more of is like those
really awkward moments like with IV
pepper or poison ivy however you want to
think about her she was a lot of fun
just watching her totally creep everyone
out I know a lot of people aren't big
fans of children on shows that are
supposed to take themselves pretty
seriously I don't think Gotham takes
itself too seriously but I feel like
they're best used in scenes like this so
just generally expecting less stunt work
from the kids more actual kids stuff
like I feel like they can do stuff that
normal kids would do like they can get
into trouble and it'll still be fun to
watch they don't need to do like Batman
level stunts number two the mayor versus
Gordon Richard kind so great as a semi
villain type character in this episode
the mayor is rearing his head he's like
institutionalized evil it's like he's
got his process he's gonna follow it he
doesn't think about it being good or
evil he just like this is what I'm gonna
do whatever this is the way it works the
same comment was made about the hunters
on Walking Dead institutionalized evil
only in that case it was cannibalism so
it is kind of funny to think of the
mayor of Gotham as being a cannibal
although I don't think that's the
direction they're going that would be
pretty crazy though the only thing I
didn't like was when Gordon told him to
kiss his ass I felt like that was almost
unintentionally hilarious as a character
though the mayor has gotten a lot more
interesting
he's way more interesting when he's
being evil like this clearly whoever is
really behind the murder is influencing
him he probably knows who it is they
said that there was a run on waynestock
clearly whoever actually initiated the
murder was the one that started that but
I think that the reason that the mayor
got so pissed at Gordon is is because
tearing down the pillars of the
community even if they're only perceived
pillars which has caused more chaos thus
you get to institutionalized evil for
Gordon's trying to do the right thing
but the mayor is trying to do the best
thing but the best thing ends up being
pretty terrible the big question after
this though is who sent Copperhead she's
another big character from the comics so
it was fun to see her but you can think
of her is like you know sub penguin
level villain penguin is like an a-list
Batman villain Copperhead very awesome
in this episode but relatively minor
character by comparison and my number
one moment
Gordon goes to Arkham I feel like we've
been waiting for this all season Gordon
is our ticket in so I'm actually really
glad that the show did this in the
context of the story
I mean he's pissed he's still trying to
find out who killed the way and so he's
not quitting the force like they want
him to but what I think is gonna end up
happening is is that we'll just spend
the second half of the season
inside Arkham Asylum where we'll get to
meet Hugo Strange and a whole bunch of
other new characters that they'll bring
on they haven't announced everyone Hugo
Strange is just one of the bigger ones
let me know that what was your favorite
moment from the episode and here's my
big question for you guys which Batman
villains do you want to see inside
Arkham that you think they have a
realistic chance of bringing on I do
think they're paving the way for Joker
and they did say that they would be able
to do them at some point I mean it's
gonna be a long time that's kind of an
ambiguous timeline so it could be season
2 could be season 3 and we don't even
know if we're gonna get a season 2 yet I
think the odds are pretty good they got
a full season pick up the 20 episode
order pretty early
just overall in general I had to give
the finale up be a little bit harder on
finales than I am on other episodes just
because so much extra work goes into
them so you expect a much bigger payoff
really the big winner to come out of
this episode just in terms of
performance is Alfred we've been waiting
all season to watch him kick some butt
got a few teases but finally we got to
see him really throw down you do not
cast the son of the doctor without
letting him kick some butt
really Alfred did spend most of the
episode just trampling all over the big
characters like cut the where's
Bruce Wayne I feel like Ben McKenzie was
just a little too on-the-nose at the end
it feels like he's taking his character
of Gordon more seriously like way more
seriously than the other actors are
taking their characters Gotham as a show
generally feels like it's supposed to be
like the fine
cheese in between arrow and the flashes
ham sandwich so I expect it to be a
little bit funny a little bit campy like
the classic TV series the 60s TV series
as well as that Tim Burton Batman films
they've got 10 more episodes so I think
that he's gonna have a lot more fun
inside Arkham hopefully that comes
across in his performance playing a big
character like Jim Gordon carries a lot
of baggage with it so I'll give him the
benefit of the doubt there are a lot of
TV series that I've really loved over
the years like Stargate for instance
totally ridiculous in his first couple
of seasons got really good past like
season 3 4 or 5 that happens all the
time with TV shows especially
long-running ones like they hit their
stride at a certain point
sometimes it takes a whole year I will
say just in general Arkham Asylum could
be a show by itself so if Gotham does
well enough over time they could
spin-off and do an Arkham show I
actually kind of feel like Gotham should
have been that like that would be much
more entertaining Gotham is interesting
I mean Gotham Central is a great comic
and it's a little easier to do in terms
of characters just because you don't
have to pay for so many licenses for all
the costumes for super villains and deal
with superpowers but if you're gonna do
a dark gritty Batman show there is no
better place than Arkham Asylum so in
the annals of TV history as we move into
season 2 or however long Gotham runs for
when people ask me about the show I
might just tell them to start watching
with the second half of season 1 like
when we get inside Arkham that's one of
the things that I'm not a big fan of
with TV shows nowadays when they adapt
stuff like they spent so much time
setting characters up when a lot of
times I feel like we all know who those
characters are so why do you need to do
their origin stories again why not just
get right to the point
Marvel is starting to do that with their
films a little bit like less origin
stories more just starting off with the
characters with their powers in their
comic book identities like if you know
who Captain America is you don't need to
show him becoming Captain America why
not just have him be cap
in America and go on whatever adventure
you want to send him on that's actually
another really good question for you
guys let me know in the comments do you
care about origin stories or would you
just rather see the villains and the
other heroes that they bring on the show
start out where they are in the comics I
really do feel like it's saved a lot of
time but I don't think that Hollywood's
gonna abandon origin stories anytime
soon there's just too many people that
do not read comics so just a quick
reminder Gotham is gonna be off the air
for a couple weeks it's gonna be on
break they haven't announced when it's
coming back yet but I will post that in
like one of my flash or arrow videos cuz
that has a couple more episodes to go
for those shows speaking of which new
flash tonight she gets real so be sure
to subscribe to get that video I'll post
it later tonight once we get through the
finales of all these comic book shows
also ranked how I thought each of them
did relative to each other far and away
though I feel like arrow is gonna come
out the clear winner but I feel like
flash is giving Gotham a run for its
money right now and just a quick
reminder new mobile links up here the
top it's the same as the link that I had
over here but click here for last week's
got them and click here for my flash
video I'll post that later tonight thank
you so much for watching so let's all
high-five see you guys a little bit
you